hey what's up guys and welcome back to
rob's world i hope you're all doing well
in my last video i showed how to make a
really cool paper ninja sword that's so
sharp
it can actually cut through an orange oh
all right so it's not that sharp but you
can still spin it around your finger or
do some pretty cool tricks so be sure to
check it out
i've been posting some sneak peeks for
some new ideas on my youtube community
post
and if you're subscribed and click the
bell and get all notifications
you'll be the first to know and you can
comment on my posts there i showed this
cool ninja star rank a few days ago
and it got over 600 likes and 247
comments from people who wanted to see
it thanks for commenting guys i also got
some comments on my instagram and
facebook page so be sure to check them
out
it takes the concept of my dollar ring
that i created and the single-sided
ninja star
and combines them together so that you
get the ninja star ring
you can even use colors or even make a
bracelet if you want
i'm going to use some colored printer
paper but if you want to use larger
origami sheets you could do that as well
once you have the paper let's get
started to make the ninja star ring we
have to first get the
excess sheet on the bottom of the
printer paper by first turning it into a
square so
like i showed you in the other tutorials
we're just going to take the corner
take the top edge and align it with the
left side
line it up and then you could tear or
cut it along this
edge now that we have the excess sheet
on the bottom
we could once again take the corner fold
it down
so that it matches up with the left side
so just crease it
and then you could flip it over fold
down that whole triangle
line it up at that edge crease it on
that edge
and then tear it once again now that we
have the pieces
separated like this we can go on to make
the ring and the mini ninja star
now we can go ahead and make the ring so
just set this little square paper aside
just take this and rotate it so that it
is vertical
and now we can take the upper right
corner and fold it down to the left so
that the top edge is aligned with the
left side
once it's lined up just make a crease
along that diagonal
and then you can unfold it and do the
same with the top left
edge fold it to the right side now
line it up with the right edge and make
a crease when you unfold it you'll see
we've made an
x in the paper we're just going to take
it and rotate it horizontally
once more and set it down on the table
take the bottom edge and fold it
up to the top edge just like this
and line it up neatly and make a crease
along the bottom
you'll see we have two edges on top and
we're going to take
both of them here and fold them down to
the bottom edge
so just round the whole thing off line
it up with the bottom
fold it down and give it a good crease
on top and as you'll see this is
actually going to be the width
of the ring you'll also notice on the
front here there is a crease that's
already in the paper here
and i'm just going to draw on it so you
could see it a little easier
we're going to fold the paper upwards on
that crease
lift it up so that the bottom edge is
vertically upwards like this
and just give it a pinch so now you'll
have something like this
we're going to take our right thumb and
pointer finger and grab it right there
on that corner
what we're going to do is we're just
going to roll our hand upside down like
this
so just roll this whole thing take the
left edge here
and put it right where our pointer is
right on top there
so just lift up your pointer and then
push down
so now we should have something like
this
you'll see we have one edge that's
facing away from us
and one that's sticking to the right
take the one that's facing away from us
and we're going to fold it towards us
right along the edge here fold it right
on top of that edge
and lift up your pointer finger and
press down now we can grab it
right here and we can slide our thumb
out now just flatten this portion out
again
now we're going to take the portion that
we just folded down and we're going to
tuck it
into the center of the ring inside
so just take it and round it off a
little bit like this
and tuck it to the inside just like that
and tuck it all the way up to this edge
here
so just push it all the way through and
give it a good pinch right here
and you'll see we have this excess here
now we could press this excess
again on top so we kind of wrapped it
around
and we're just going to press it on top
like that and give it a good pinch
now you'll see we should be able to
actually fit the ring to our finger
this actually can slide now through this
little box that we made
so as you'll see it can slide back and
forth
and what we're going to do is we're just
going to open it a little bit
and just try our finger on so just see
it fits pretty well i'm just going to
take it off
the amount of excess here should be a
little bit wider
than the box here maybe a quarter of an
inch once it's just like that
we're going to take this excess and
we're going to fold it on top
of this little piece right here so just
fold it right on top of the box to the
left
and as you'll see there's a little bit
of excess sticking over the left edge
here
we're just going to hold it like this
upside down
and this is the excess portion that we
need to get right in here
so to do that take your pointer finger
and push in here and make a
dent so you're just going to kind of
dent it like that
open it up a little bit and now we could
take this corner
and we're going to squish it in there
just press it in there like that
really hard do the same with the other
corner
so it's all the way in there and now we
could take that dent
and just flatten it or pop it back out
and what that does is it actually locks
the ring in place
so now you'll see we have a ring that
should fit your finger now we can make
the ninja star
now that we have the ring we can make
the mini ninja star and as you can see
it is very small
but i have faith in my subscribers
because i've taught this ninja star a
bunch of times it's special because it
has a little sleeve
on the back of it here as you could see
the back is different than the front
and it's that sleeve that allows it to
join to the origami ring just like that
and that way it can kind of be
interlocked as you can see
so let's make the ninja star now to make
it we just need to take the square that
we had before
fold it in half and then we can crease
it
and tear it in half when we do that
we'll get two equal sheets and i'm going
to be using colored paper here just
because it's easier to demonstrate and
what we're going to do
is take it and hold them so that the
little triangle here the crease is on
the bottom right of both pieces
and they're both going to be made the
same way so i'm just going to go through
one of them
and then i'll quickly do the other one
we're going to take the top edge and
fold it down to the bottom edge just
like this
and align them as neatly as you can make
a crease
and then we can take the left edge and
fold it across to the right edge
once again make a crease now you can
unfold it
and we can flip it upside down and
you'll see the reason i positioned it
like that is because we have a small
crease in the paper so we're just going
to take the right side and fold it down
on that crease
so that the top edge is on that vertical
line so the right side goes down
the left side goes up so left
up right down then we could flip it
upside down
and you'll see we have these two little
boxes we're going to take the upper
right corner
fold it down to the lower left corner
just like that and then take the lower
left corner
and fold it up to the upper right
corner like that then we could take the
two
triangles that we have here and as
you'll see it makes a
z and we'll fold these two triangles
inwards to the middle so now that we
finish that piece
let's make the other one really quickly
so just make another identical piece
by folding in half both ways the left
side goes up the right side goes down
flip it fold the boxes inwards and then
the triangles in
and now we're ready to interlock them to
complete the ninja star ring
to interlock the pieces with the ring
grab the ring and hold it so that the
box is facing downwards and grab one of
the pieces
open up the flaps so that they're facing
towards you and slide it
underneath the band so that you have two
flaps on either side
and you can kind of close them like this
you might have to adjust them a little
bit later
but just make sure that you can fold
them completely downwards
then you could open them back up and
grab the other piece
and we're also going to open up the
flaps gently and
hold it so that this piece in the middle
this middle
part is parallel with the band and it
sort of forms an
x with the other piece once you have it
like this
we can close all four of the flaps now
in a clockwise direction
starting with this one so that's one
then we'll go to this one
two three you might have to adjust it
you might have to kind of bend it a
little farther
finally the last one is going to go over
this one
and kind of into here just lift up this
one a little bit so just lift up the
first one
so that you can kind of see the pocket
there see it
and then curve this one over
the third one and underneath and then
slide that one back in and then you can
just work it all together like this
adjust it as necessary and you have
completed the ninja star ring
so let's see how it looks and it looks
pretty awesome
if you were interested in making the
bracelet you can take the sheet holding
it like this and splitting it in
quarters to get a longer section
then just use the same technique that we
use for the ring to interlock the ends
making sure that you have enough excess
to lock them together then you could use
a bigger star like the ones in my other
tutorials interlock it like that
to get the bracelet i hope you guys
enjoyed the video for the ninja star
ring if you did smash that like button
down below and don't forget to subscribe
and click that notification bell if
you're not already
i really appreciate all the support on
my channel i went to the smoky mountains
recently and all i could say is that it
was just really majestic there was a lot
of wildlife to be seen there
like bears and deer there were so many
rivers and lakes
and i even started my own fire using a
ferro rod
fun to exercise my survival skills
a sea turtle also recently got tangled
on my line while i was fishing but no
worries she was alright and swam off
safely
and uninjured after i did a little exam
and let me know if you have an idea for
a video post it in the comments below
and i might make it
thanks a lot for watching and i'll see
you soon